outside of La outside of Cali if you
could do a joint mixtape album with
another rapper who would it be
right now yeah right now
outside L.A can't be California the
state of California is off limits and
anyone who signed your label is off
limits
younger oh it could be anybody y'all
give me a young and an old both all
right go first who what younger old
young young
um Boston Boston Ridge peacefire yeah
so Boston Richie on the young side what
about on the old side hey fire
outside uh
uh
dead or alive
let's be honest yeah I mean yeah you
could say [ __ ] two pockets he was
from New York and Baltimore but you know
that would be cheating okay uh
not from L.A guys just so you didn't
know yeah yeah right like you know
because there's a lot of artists from La
I would love to do mixtapes with you
know nope I'm just saying I would love
to hear you in Blast do a project that
would be kind of hard you wouldn't see I
think would be dope what's up let me
fire what's over so
um I don't know I don't know about human
bust the Rhymes would be dope you think
so yeah why not you guys could [ __ ]
go on a tour and you guys can [ __ ]
try to outperform each other be a lot of
calories burned on stage I think I got
them right now though he dope though
because I just seen him right not to be
turned up but about another [ __ ] though
but I'm just saying uh
I seen him do some [ __ ] on stage bro
that was dope as [ __ ] it didn't take a
lot of energy it just was real
like it just had it was just real like
Poise yeah you know what I mean like he
he he act like he he act like he [ __ ]
up
Lord know what he do he uh
he went he uh the music was turned up
and then he turned it down like but he
rapping though and he going low he going
low he going low he going low and then
he turned the [ __ ] back up and I'm
looking at this and like this [ __ ]
genius it's amazing it's [ __ ] genius
so I'm just like damn it's certain
things like that I like to take when I
like to steal though but yeah steal it I
got blood a lot of people do that it's
not like Busta Rhymes is the only guy
doing that
let's see who else you know I'm doing
that I've seen that before I can't tell
you off the top of my head it was
something else you did though I just
wanted to you know mainly expose his
little his show but yeah I mean he's on
tour right now with Wu Tang and if you
can go see it for your [ __ ] self I
mean go see uh Busta Rhymes on tour
right now go see Busta Rhymes the tour
might be over actually
Wu-Tang I like that show yeah
if you can get all night well you can't
get all nine guys because you know all
right Peter ODB but if you could get
Method Man to show up to a woo show it's
amazing meth is very like
he's kind of like one foot in one foot
out on the woo [ __ ] I think he only did
like four of the dates on the tour let
them has a dope performance of amazing
and he's young I seen this big ass [ __ ]
stage dog bro that [ __ ] was crazy Method
Man Method Man stays these days though
bro and [ __ ] nobody caught him oh man
bro this [ __ ] is a fool he got up like
it was nothing shook it off and [ __ ] I'm
like it's [ __ ] big as [ __ ] bro that
[ __ ] I think a [ __ ] got kicked
in the face excuse me I don't mean to
say [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah you know but
yeah it's a term of endearment nah
because I got a lot of female I got a
lot of female fans it sounds good on the
record it sounds great it sounds great
on the record but you know coming
without a beat it don't sound like yeah
that's fair I got a lot of females I
respect you know what I'm saying we only
disrespect women on Beats
so look
this but I say that [ __ ] one time I
started stage I did that [ __ ] one time
you've jumped off stage did you get
caught no I didn't get caught I think I
kicked someone in the head nobody even
knew me though at that time